conflict kitchen developed with Don
Valesky who's my partner in the project
she now lives in California but she was
working with me and we have our the side
of our waffle shop has its own little
storefront and that's where our kitchen
is and literally we were challenged by
the hip-hop restaurant he had a hot dog
guy selling food outside and he said and
I was like you know that's preventing
people from coming in our waffle shop
you do the booze we do the food he's
like come on man your fake business why
don't you compete you know so I was like
that's it you laid it down we're gonna
compete and we decided we'll open a
restaurant but obviously we're not gonna
sell waffles because that's the thing
that brings people in for the show what
would we do if we could create a rest a
takeout restaurant in Pittsburgh and we
started off with what was missing from
Pittsburgh and all the things I
described originally and so how can we
be all of those things at once how can
we eat every restaurant that's never
existed how can we be a center for
political discussion how can we create
presents for cultures and ethnic groups
that no one's paying attention to or
that have small populations within our
city and how can we do it in a way
that's really truly engaging so we
created the conflict kitchen essentially
what you're looking at is a facade
that's just stuck on to the building
we got around any permitting because
it's it's off the ground a little bit so
if you if you were on the ground you got
to get a permit if you go out into the
public right away a certain amount of
space you got to get a permit with
everything unfolds or folds out and then
folds down and basically we're running
two restaurants out of one kitchen so
we're competing with ourselves which
again is like an irrational business
strategy the other strategy I mean a lot
of people it's funny because we're
talking now that it's kind of moved
through the internet there's like a
Russian social entrepreneurship group
that has approached a several times
about like can you present to our social
entrepreneur group and Russia and like I
what I we've we stumbled upon the whole
strategy when we presented this to
people no one liked the idea no one
wanted to give us any money because
you're gonna sell food that has no
market in Pittsburgh it's not a pizza
joint it's not
you know whatever you're gonna ask
people to talk about politics with
strangers
in the public space Americans hate that
and as soon as someone gets used to it
you're gonna go out of business and
change to another restaurant that does
the same thing so they're like three bad
business model ideas which have all
turned out to be good business model
ideas and maybe if we weren't artists if
we were entrepreneurs we would never
have gotten to this point so the very
first version was an Iranian one
obviously the visuals are really quite
important right it has to be striking it
has to get people we want it to be
anomalous to the landscape to the visual
landscape of the city we also want to
privilege the Farsi over the English
we're the only were the only Persian
restaurant the city has had we worked
with with local Iranians as well as
folks in Iran I have many friends I've
developed over the years and other
projects who were living in Iran you
know the impetus at the time which was
almost four years ago was looking at the
the rhetoric within media that was very
similar to the build-up to the Iraq war
right cases were being made and a very
simplified discourse was being put out
and I'm friends there where the
discourse is complicated I mean if we
all talked about even Obama at this
moment none of us would agree exactly
right it's not about simplification we
were thinking can we create a place that
actually complicates people's
perspective and can we sell really
really good food as the seduction
towards that it's just can we bypass
audiology with just hunger and and can
we engage people on a daily basis and
you know can we not just be a
fly-by-night pop up we're not a pop up
we're a restaurant that's been in the
city for three years we were pop-up the
first week and the first month became
less of a pop up this pop-up kind of
thing to me sometimes it's kind of
irritating because it implies a lack of
real depth and commitment and it applies
also that we know what we're doing we're
going to pop up and tell it to you what
we're doing is we're creating a space
for co-education
learning with us between ourselves and
everyone else who comes to us in the
city and to do that you got to be around
you have to have a call-and-response
system not just a you know an iterative
system so the idea was let's use the
food
let's has the food also be a mechanism
for carrying information right so
obviously food is an incredible
storytelling device in and of itself the
food comes wrapped in interviews that we
did with irani ins again on a variety of
cultural and political topics often
contradictory each other as we are like
to do folks who've never had Persian
food you know might just think oh this
is kind of like a weird cuisine and that
could be a great way to start but then
they might think Oh what does this
relate to the culture in cuisines of
either you know my community or my city
this space the space that opens up when
you're waiting when you're ordering
right this is a kind of the same
performative space as the talk show in
some capacity a little bit more
open-ended but also more focused in
terms of the nature of the conversation
our idea was to be disruptive to not to
have people come with a question like
how do you get people to come with a
question to create a space of curiosity
that their initiative like what is this
place it looks weird to me and then fill
that space that's a really fertile
environment right that curiosity in too
much curiosity total befuddlement you
don't get anything and and if it's to
normal you have no one caring that space
doesn't get opened up so when that space
gets opened up it gets filled by our
staff who are really just expert
conversationalist they're not experts on
any one of the given topics their
cultural junkies their political junkies
they're following the information but
they're just trying to catalyze that
moment between them and the customer and
they're not you know to me the worst
thing is you can just sort of spout your
own ideologies and shut down a
conversation so this is our Afghan
version of the project after about five
or six months we switch
this is the Venezuelan version this is a
recent trip to Cuba where now we have a
full-time chef who's amazing
cooking in homes cooking in local
restaurants interviewing folks I won't
go into great depth this is the North
Korean embassy so we knew we wanted to
do a North Korean version this was the
closest we could get we rang the
doorbell literally and they a attache
came out talked to us from 45 minutes
I'll go over that a little bit later so
we open the Cuban version of the project
so the food is one level there's also
projects and events that we do so we
take a table like this we take a much
larger projection screen on the screen
is a space in Tehran so it's a
Pittsburgh Tehran dinner party in which
on their side they're eating they pushed
their table up against the space and
essentially we're sharing this another
version of the meal this is in
Pittsburgh this is in Tehran we're all
cooking the same Persian recipes
ironically we made Arsenal from scratch
and my friend Sara bought it all at the
store a lot of canned stuff which was
part of the conversation right at that
time the second time we did it the
sanctions the second level of serious
sanctions were in place to cook from
scratch was actually more expensive than
to to buy from the store similar events
we've done with Afghan filmmakers we do
culture cultural festivals school groups
are coming in we've used the Billboard
as a way of catalyzing conversation the
line was for us that was our event yes
we had yeah right
a paladar so you know while we were down
for a little bit looking for a new
location we basically just functioned
out of someone's home and then we've
recently a year ago moved to probably
the most central spot in the city which
is the Schenley Plaza it's right between
the University of Pittsburgh Carnegie
Mellon across from the Carnegie main
library and we've gone from having 30 to
50 people at the old location a day to
having during a summertime we'd have two
to three hundred people changes the
nature of what we do and just had to
make us be more nimble about how we can
actually engage with folks what its
accelerated is our capacity number one
it's a full kitchen we make a lot more
food we have this built-in audience of
you know folks who are just hanging out
during lunch everyday and you know we're
open from 11 to 6 so that audience kind
of changes as a publishing venue it's
probably been the most remarkable thing
we've accidentally discovered that we're
a great publishing venue people really
read the rapper's they read there's a
North Korean cookbook there's other
materials we hand out in that space you
have during lunchtime to you kind of put
aside maybe you'll be on your phone but
you might read something actually works
for us so that's kind of one of the ways
in which we we story tell and you know I
know there's a center for you know
rethinking documentary here or not all
of my work is fundamentally nonfiction
but it's I very early on recognize how
nonfiction is a completely constructed
and playful genre so in that realm this
is a project that we do called the
foreigner so you come to eat and we say
how would you like to have your Persian
meal with syrup he's living in Iran
right now and you can have lunch with
him around the corner through a human
avatar who is our employee Lise
so at least just sits around the corner
and in her headphones she has sera blots
simple right so Rob is live anything sir
Rob says she just automatically repeats
and the customer the customer has a
little microphone so Saurabh hears
directly what the customer says so
Elysee is basically this empty vessel
but she's also a hyperlocal human body
she's someone you recognize she's
someone who looks familiar she's someone
you've seen in the window if you've come
to the restaurant before and this to me
is the metaphor for the project in
general right is this number one trying
to create a simultaneity of place of
being here and there of being us in them
and and also like how do you know these
stories that sir Rob there is telling
you can sure you can do it on skype and
talk to him directly but how do you make
people pay attention again you knowing
what actually makes things uncanny in
life so that to me the fundamental
artistic impulse is to make what's
familiar unfamiliar so that we're in the
present moment again this in some
capacity both takes you out of the
present because you don't know where
you're located but also brings you into
the present and it complicates identity
which you know he's a man she's a woman
sometimes we have older people doing it
younger people so these are just some
customers a lot of times I'll pilot and
try these projects out in other cities
so I tried this out in Cleveland in the
public library and in the shopping mall
these are the human avatars for these
irani ins throughout public space so
these happen in different ways where
folks would just approach you and say
hey you know what's what's the what's
life like here right now a totally
confused person you know a fish out of
water that then slowly realize that
they're not here even though they seem
to be here we did a similar thing at the
San Diego Museum in the Persian gallery
where you meet you're told to find this
woman who's a local and she is a avatar
for our friend Saurabh who runs a
Artspace in Tehran so you're in a
gallery field of ancient Persian works
and he's in a gallery of contemporary
art so you have the juxtaposition of the
space of the work and of the individual
kind of happening another project that
got piloted outside of the restaurant
and brought back was Don and I were
invited to be part of it by anyone in
Porto Alegre Brazil so I'll walk you
through the project it happens in this
main city Square Park rather and there's
a lake and so when you walk up to the
lake there's these signs to tell you
that there you can take free rides with
Barack Obama Google Shabbos and and then
there's a series of speeches that will
happen over the next five weeks as
people line up to sign up to take these
rides which are swan boats already
pre-existing we made our own version of
the sign where you could take a free
ride with Chavez or Obama and then we
hired and then we hired actors we hired
actors who played Chavez or Obama and uh
you know very quickly because there's a
very huge project you know Brazil you
could see in terms of write Venezuelan
socialist policies have been very
influential throughout Latin America let
alone Brazil but the you know the IMF is
perhaps the most embedded partner Brazil
has so you know United States in in
Venezuela present very interesting polls
but also Chavez and Obama are these very
romantic figures that people project
they're irrational hatred and love on
very polarizing and so we thought well
these will be great kind of devices to
elicit stories from the Brazilian public
so what happens is you're invited to
take a ride in during the ride Obama
like a lover would say what do you think
of me after a little while you know
and the public would say everything they
really thought of it and and maybe they
break up at the end or they fall in love
I don't know
and the same with Chavez so he would
come up in a way they would work is they
come up to you on the dock like would
you like to take a ride and this this
issue of seduction is something Kathryn
and I have talked about you know how do
you seduce people into something that's
maybe didactic in some capacity or
political or ideological or you know
problematic so you take their pride and
he records what you're saying so then
those recordings are taken verbatim
scripted and the scripts become the
speeches that the politicians give every
afternoon so here you can see on these
floating platforms there's Obama and
there's Chavez throughout the park
there's speakers so during the two to
three hours that they're giving this
speech you'll come up to the park and
you'll hear Java is giving us it there
in Portuguese oh you're here Obama and
Portuguese giving a speech sometimes
they overlap the speeches and the
speeches are filled with first-person
opinion right but the president embodies
them he presents them as if they're his
viewpoints and what you get is a
politician who says what you wanted to
say who's really self-critical or
self-aggrandizing or actually factually
incorrect about himself
or actually a lot of things talk about
Brazil you know and via Obama who's a
very powerful individual so the romance
is then turned into politics is turned
into documentary is turned into
storytelling so both of these guys were
in a play about Michael Jackson at the
time
so okay so we've done versions of this
at Compline kitchen we've done and I've
got stuff that can hand out we published
something called the Iranian speech and
the Iranian speech is a speech this
crowd source bought from Iran ian's we
asked the Iranians what would you like
to hear Barack Obama said give us part
of a speech right part of the speech
then we compiled that speech and hire a
local Barack Obama imitator to give the
speech to the public that's just
gathering outside of conflict kitchen
we've subsequently also done a Cuban
speech which I think we have some
versions of here so we've published the
speech and then another version in this
time we decided we could get a much
larger audience through our social media
which has become pretty large at this
point so we hired the number one Barack
Obama imitator in the world he lives in
LA
his name's Ron he has this studio next
his kitchen is right behind the flag and
and we gave him the speech and then we
disseminated it through public media
I'll play a little bit we turn that up
yeah
for their future generations
[Music]
rebuilt by its citizens a country
respected by the international community
or will it be known as a country destroy
at the whim of the elite and powerful we
cannot remain silent for fear so these
are the thoughts of actual Cubans Cuba
Cuba will change if we want to do we
must support the people's will to change
their country I actually forget the last
time defending human rights but then we
have trade and have close ties to China
and Vietnam and Russia we have Cuba 90
miles from us and yet we have forgotten
all about it
Americans we care more about things that
happen too far away then close to our
shores on this jump around a little bit
day the United States reaches out a hand
to your citizens
but not they don't even see him I really
think they want to be capitalists at
heart no there is a Cuban woman I know
in Miami that never worked a day in her
life and she gets Social Security and
Vietnam is a communist country we have
even established negotiations with North
Korea and now is Syria and those are
countries that have worked good homes
and sometimes fought against the United
bin public's lack of information with
the aim of connecting citizens all over
the world the Cuban government has
persecuted civil society so you can see
it's a schizophrenic speech it's it's
filled with with Pro and anti Castro you
know people for different types of
policy and you know there's a simple
construct that we're using so that the
voices don't become simplified you know
we want to get a debate out there we
don't we want to you know it's sort of
people talk about metrics a lot we're
not really into metrics we're into
encouraging curiosity
now what we could say how do we measure
whether curiosity has been encouraged as
artists I feel like I've got a good
sense before engaging curiosity or not
and we're always trying to experiment
like is this interesting enough am I
going to want to engage with it so other
byproducts of the this is an individual
project I did the City of Columbus next
to their State House it's a live time
and temperature from Tehran is played in
Columbus again this idea of simultaneity
of space we do something called the the
lunch hour this is a local Syrian
doctors been giving support to rebels in
Syria a way to so now we have folks who
come to us everyday like hey you're
gonna do a Syrian version or you're
gonna do an Egyptian version a Czech
version and our chance to kind of move a
little quicker is to have these weekly
lunches our current version is focused
around North Korea obviously this is the
the hardest one to research I was in
Shanghai the closest I could get to
North Korean is a state-run restaurant
by the North Korean government they
actually have in several countries which
is really like a chuck-e-cheese meet
shangri-la version of North Korea
incredibly bizarre and you can't really
record anything there's a stage show on
the William Tell Overture happens in the
middle of it and it's it's really
disturbing and disconcerting but what we
did was we actually we are now working
on a project with North Korean defectors
in Anyang which is a city south of Seoul
and our research was to go there
initially to interview folks to cook to
hang out with the defector community to
go into North Korea you can go but it's
a very controlled experience so the
recipes all come out of those direct
experiences and they're brought back to
our venues sometimes we've done an event
this event for 250 people where if you
sit on the right side of the table
you're getting a South Korean dish and
if you sit on the left side you're
getting a North Korean dish so there's
that the arbitrary differentiation and
separation that's given but you know one
of the things that you learn is that you
know this is a you know Korea's been one
Korea for thousands of years the
politics of 60 years doesn't really
create a culinary separation although
the politics of food
Korea is based on what is accessible you
know so Koreans or North Koreans are
only eating meat you know two or three
times a year so weird by default a
vegetarian restaurant at this time one
of the other events I was telling Griff
about that we're doing now that we are
having this sort of international
following is a cooking lesson this is
using kind of like Google hangout this
is just Skype like a premier account
where you can get ten videos up and we
have the North Korean chef that we've
been working with is giving a lesson in
Seoul to nine other people who are in
different cities and the way we do it is
everyone first set you sign up for it
right and if you're in Buenos Aires we
give you the recipe the ingredients to
shop for and that's one of the
interesting challenge right it's - you
got to get your local version of what
you could find in North Korea even in
Seoul they have to get the local version
of what they could find in north and
then and then we all cook together and
the greatest part was and we're all like
grading potatoes it's like an orchestra
so I'll show you I think I have a little
clip
so everyone introduced so after
introduction we go into and then we just
sit down eat have a conversation
together one of the nice things about
this you know as you guys sit you're
involved in technology I'm sure you've
done a lot of Skype
you know Skype is tough when you have a
group there's one person at a time this
because everyone is doing an action you
know and you're not just serve like all
paying attention you can the
conversation was much more organic and
casual so someone's like soy sauce to
you you you know is there a specific way
which you use soy sauce or you do not
use soy sauce is a fish sauce and soy
sauce you're kind of just asking a
functional question within your recipe
that then oftentimes organically flows
into perhaps even a political question
so I'm going to end with I added these
so just to talk about this bizarre way
in which the project has hit a kind of
cultural zeitgeist and the portals in
which people enter or become aware of it
the biggest one is through the food is
through the kind of foodie movement
that's going on and and I can't say I'm
barely a foodie glyphs and foodie we
hire people who are really amazing
foodie but the second one would be
actually through tourism
I forgot to mention that so we've become
a tourist destination visit Pittsburgh
which is our main tourist bureau mostly
because we got attention beforehand now
has this on the tour of alternative
spaces in Pittsburgh so people always
come in buy from other countries then
there's the news outlets that are
interested in it
and then the international attention
which is frankly way more than the
national people are asking us to do
franchises on a weekly basis majority of
them are in like South Africa in New
Zealand in in Warsaw so that the
perception folks have of us from the
outside is often that we're way better
than we are in the inside I always feel
like we're never fully actualized I mean
we could be a much better project and we
could be more engaging we can figure out
more creative solutions to how the our
city our first constituent our customers
can become more curious and informed
citizens and I hope that we're starting
to create a civic impact and the thing
about Pittsburgh is it's so small
everyone in the city knows about it so
if I say conflict Hitchin people know
about it and we have I feel like in that
way we've been able to shift the
identity of the city itself and it's
also people love the story this bizarre
thing in Pittsburgh you know that to
them is a narrative and I totally
embraced that cognitive dissonance that
seemed that people seem to have about
Pittsburgh having this really you know
incredible culture project the other
important thing is that we're open 7
days a week
we're like the hardware store we're like
the the grocery we're like any other
business we you know we've got a revenue
we've got bills to pay and we think
about economics as much as anyone else
and it's not for free it's not just a
fancy art project we're business we're
struggling and trying to survive is
along with all the other businesses and
I think that gives us a type of
credibility to our customers who are
also interested in our kind of non
business ideas so I'm gonna end with
maybe one of the most bizarre media yeah
if we can pull the sound here I was in
Italy recently and I was giving a
presentation and my friend called me up
after the presentation he said did you
know that you're on the Italy's national
game show I said no I did not know
and then we found it online teaching
plan
[Applause]
little Minnesota the crucifix is a
completely sudden it is honeycomb
frito-lay there are a plenty on the
board she go prefer cold water in the
end of the party will have to stimulate
reproduction of strains from there are
food for another movie because it is
starting to resent you
mirin and we're arc of rhubarb in its
way a lot of coriander
so like you can't hire Valente to do to
be your spokesmodel